I think I've got two favorite sports
moments this year and they're not really
huge significant but uh they really are
really enjoyed watching them the one was
man United's win over arsenal of A2
sorry for any Arsenal supporters out
there and the other one was a Jamaican
athlete called Johan Blake he ran 19.26
which was pretty much very close to
Usain Bolt's world record but his
reaction time was extremely slow and I'm
pretty excited for next year's Olympic
Games I think he's probably going to be
the man to beat in the 200.
uh I don't really have any previous
superstitions but there are a lot of
things we do pre-race to make sure that
the performance is at its best so
whether it be from diets or from taking
ice baths the night before in the
morning of to just go into the track and
doing uh the same routine warm-up that
we'll do on the race day in the morning
and the day before
and then I always put my number on my on
my on my on my vest the night before and
make sure my clothes are packed up
perfectly for the next day so I guess
there's some things that I do that if I
don't follow I guess I'll get a bit
nervous
yeah there's some music I listen to to
get myself excited and in other races I
feel like maybe I'm a bit too excited so
I listen to music to calm me down so at
the moment this season I was listening
to Deadmau5 and uh sometimes I'll just
listen to classical music to kind of
calm me down a bit
I think my personal Styles kind of just
laid back I like clothes that uh that
fit properly and maybe a bit loose
fitting and then I like to stick to
natural colors
I don't usually wear things that are
kind of art there but I mix and match a
bit so uh my favorite pair of sneakers
are lime green and I like them a lot but
I hardly ever wear them but uh yeah I'd
say my style is pretty laid back
yeah I think in life you're always going
to get criticism I know I've got a fair
show of it in the past um you know as
the years have progressed I see a lot of
people
um the commentary of the the comments
surrounding should I should or shouldn't
be able to compete have become less and
less and I see people
noticing that there aren't any other
paralympic athletes running similar
times using the same prosthetic legs
that I've had and then also you know
we've done all the tests that we need to
do with the iwa if which is the
organization which controls Athletics
and they're very happy having me run in
the competition so I've been quite happy
in the last year and I guess there'll
always be some sort of criticism but I
think it's maybe five percent of of the
whole bigger picture
I had a couple of sporting Idols growing
up I used to watch Formula One so Nigel
Mansell was one of my heroes and Mark
Tyson was one of my my childhood Heroes
I think he was a great Sportsman you
know and I really enjoyed watching
boxing as a kid and even now you know
I've got some guys to look up to and
Gaza Valentino Rossi is a an athlete and
a sportsman I think is a phenomenal guy
he's accomplished a lot and he's still
very humble and I think that puts me of
any Sportsman you know somebody that can
achieve a greatness but stay at the top
and after their career still be a top
top look